he's out of the green room and he's back
in green and white for the first time
since college
he's new york jets running back le'veon
bell here on the rich eisen show how are
you levion
man i'm feeling amazing man i appreciate
you oh come on
i've been waiting for this you know that
you know that yeah i know
no i know i mean in the green room
you're like yeah i'll come on your show
uh and i just didn't know i did did i
have to franchise tag you to get you on
the show levion
well i know you don't respond you don't
respond too well to that sort of thing
anyway so i just was just hoping you'd
call and now here you are i'm so excited
yeah yeah well so what is it like i mean
uh
you know you're back you're sweating
you're in you're you're you're back in
pads
i'm wondering what it's like for you
le'veon right now
um to be honest man that feels leaving
you know
um i i feel like last week when i turned
out in the field and
you know did the conditional class and
got the first practice out
it just felt good that you don't want to
order you know nine cents out of the way
you know to get back on the field
and uh just get back to playing football
you know and i think over this past week
i even got better i'm taking a little
bit of the real stuff as people were
saying
and um today i felt even more better you
know so i'm paying for this year
it's gonna be a fun year i'm excited to
you know show some people that
you know um i'm still the same player
that i have if not better um i want to
go out here and you know
try to be you know a leader and show
people what i feel
this sounds this sounds like a man with
a very healthy soft tissue
uh situation going on right now
and i hope and i hope you're healthy and
strong and i hope you have a great year
levion
doctor
well i don't know if you saw then then
you must have seen that i
went over the top and i said
that i think i rich i know you got god
yeah i mean i think you're you're set to
be a record setter for yourself right
now
that you gonna have of the the all-time
best in
in rushing and total touchdown so you're
gonna back my play here right le'veon
i am
le'veon bell here on the rich eisen show
but i in all due respect to my compadre
across the way there
i think he is giving voice to a lot of
what people think is that you're
you've been out of football for a year
and that and inevitably if you're if
you're
you you can't uh be as successful as
possible if you're not
always in football period
le'veon do you have you taken any steps
to try and over the last few months
mimic in a way what might be actual
football quality
action le'veon so to be heard
the first couple weeks the first couple
days inside this
um i crimped up a little bit just
because of the fact that it's not
you can do all the training you want and
short to the t-shirt you know i was
training in miami and humanity
everything but you still can't really
replicate football you know you got to
actually be playing football
to kind of be in football shape you know
so i can run it all day i can run
conditioning one day
no gases and sprints all day but it's
like this one when you put on equipment
when you're 30 pounds heavier you gotta
make cuts when you not knowing you got
to make a cut
um jogging back to the huddle no huddle
things like that you can't really
replicate you gotta actually be in the
game of football so
i mean the first two three days when i
was in here i was snapping a little bit
um i think you know the hydration part
was hard for me just because i hadn't
been out of football for you know over a
year
you know the heat out here was crazy
just being an equipment
back into my rhythm and things like that
but over this past
week i felt like i got better at that
you know so
um i'm i'm excited you know it's
definitely challenges that came with it
you know but it just you know getting
back into the football rhythm that's all
it is you're getting back to the
football rhythm and i think
uh i'm on my way and i'm going in the
right direction le'veon bell jets
running back here on the rich eisen show
what's your relationship like with your
coach adam gase levion
man i love engage you know um he he's
like
he's really the first offensive minded
coach i've literally ever played for
um and in the fact that i i literally
can like see him calling the plays and i
know his ideas of where he's trying to
go with the offense
and it gets me excited because i know
what type of
situations and positions he can put me
in um to help
to make it easier for me you know don't
get me wrong
you can have a talented player and they
can go out there and you know they can
you know showcase their talents but it
can still be difficult at times
but he kind of makes it easy on me you
know he he gives me the ball and open
spots
um it's possible maybe i only got to
make a guide miss rather than me being
in the box and i got eight nine god in
the box sometimes
a lot of six-man seven-man boxes now you
know and he's making it easier for me
to get into open space uh when i catch
the ball
got my shoulder square downfield so you
gotta have my back
towards the defense all the time you
know so he's doing a
good job of just putting me in
situations where i'm able to just
make a play and it's easier on me you
know i don't have to make so many people
miss and things like that
um he does does a great job of rotating
dollars you know we got ty montgomery
he's
he's a guy who can come in i'll spill me
he can be in the game with me
uh we got all type of guys on the
outside so i just think he does a great
job of really
putting guys in position to make plays
and it makes it easier on them
and at the same time you know everybody
everybody making plays
you know using this kind of a spin all
around sam spread the ball around
they just make things easier for the
offense
that's what that's what did you ever
have a conversation with him about the
comments ascribed to him about your
salary
when you were a free agent did you ever
ever sit down with him on that le'veon
bell
no to be honest we never had a sit down
no we just need to
at work or you know wherever i feel
about what we talking
we just know like oh that's just the
media stuff um
me and him our relationship is it is
what it is you know we we love each
other right
we need to really pay no margin because
at the end of the day we know what it
was
we know where our goal is so i didn't
let it bother me
um and you know he didn't let it bother
him you know me
addressing to the media and everything
uh we just kept moving all day
i don't want to be behold all that
baggage and stuff and letting people
kind of put things in my ear because i
know what it was i'm engaged
um when i've been talking to him and now
i'm in the building and the fact that
he's running the offense the way he is
on the offense i know what it is you
know he's excited
that i'm on the team and i'm excited
that he's coaching me le'veon bell here
on the rich eisen show
uh tell me about darnold what are you
seeing so many people talk about how
special he is you've got a front row
seat levion
oh my goodness um yeah this kid is
i've never had the opportunity to really
play with a younger quarterback so
um you know i was in college i played
with kirkland he's older i worked in nfl
play with benny loader
but then i got a younger guy in the
huddle with me and i literally just
watched him grow in front of my eyes
it's really special to see
uh literally from the minitab
to now um it's literally i feel like
i've seen two different quarterbacks and
that's only
you know in a couple months you know so
i feel like
the growth with him is only you know
it's kind of scary you know it's kind of
scary to see it you know because
the sky isn't working for him i'm glad i
could be a part of it and i can really
help him out
um in certain situations and the same at
the same time he's helping me out he
will make things easier on me
so i'm excited you know i can't wait to
go out there i'm gonna be in battle with
him
so um in terms of your numbers this year
le'veon
not many people are talking about you as
a first overall selection in fantasy
football this year and i know you've
already been talking about this a little
bit
do you feel like you've been forgotten
levion
um yeah of course you know and i think
um that's more of a human nature thing
you know
a lot of people when you don't see
something for a long time you tend to
forget you know that's
normal um you know you go to the nba you
don't see lebron for a whole playoff
year
and it's like oh blah blah blah i think
like that
this is how it is you know so i don't
think offense to it i just feel like
uh when i get back on the sale and
people see it
everybody you know that's why i'm not
really impressed about it i'm just ready
to go out there and play football that's
what i'm really ready to do
and and you know you you made a
tongue-in-cheek apology uh on twitter to
fantasy owners who drafted you last year
you know i always do keep it real with
you
there are some there are some steelers
fans who are a little upset that
that there was no apology in their
direction based on what happened with
you last year do you feel like you owe
one
maybe to that fan base um i mean
apologies for what not playing yeah or
what
i mean in a way
i don't know i wish i could tell the
fans that i wasn't friends but
um like at the same time i was making a
business decision for myself
you know so um i i apologize for
you know not being on the field and and
helping the team
uh because i i had made a bigger
business decision but i don't regret you
know sitting out and doing what i did
this is the fact that
i have to worry about myself and and my
family you know and
um i made the decision um i'll live with
the decision i'm happy with the
decisions i made
you know so i'm not gonna look back on
it um but you know to the student fans
and things like that you know i'll do a
point of view like being there
um and not be able to you know showcase
my time
and the way the contact situation went i
wish it was smoother
but um it didn't come out smooth you
know and
i just want to leave that where it is
and i want to keep moving forward well
and again you know
it's situations are totally different
and i totally get that
you know but what advice would you give
maybe to zeke elliott and melvin gordon
right now two running backs who feel
like
they're not getting their market value
uh or in a court situation zeke might be
similar to yours where
he's being told by management that that
he's not
deserving of a market reset at the
position
or they're not willing to do it for him
what advice would you give those running
backs right now le'veon bell
um you know to be honest you know just
go with your gut go with your heart you
know
um with the envelope i feel like both of
those guys
they're such a valuable part to the team
you know so i don't like what i have to
know you gotta look on tv and you see
those guys gotta hold out just how to
get
what they want i hate seeing it you know
um but
i understand you know the guys of course
they're trying to do the business
and the guys upstairs don't really not
even just those guys but these people in
general don't really
respect the running back value but i
think you know when you see
when you when god like when a guy likes
you come out or a guy like
doesn't come out and those things are
with the cowboys
not out there i don't want to see what
it looks like so some people
think he is
so and those guys go out there they're
playing
they're riding the ball they're catching
so they're running back and catching the
ball and they're part line
because they're blocking too so the fact
that they're doing all three of the
phases of the game i feel like they need
to get to
that market value they need to get with
their worst period you know so
i i'm behind those guys i think behind
those guys i hope they get
on what they deserve you know and i want
to know i'm gonna be one of those guys
i hope uh they they do get what they do
what they deserve all right last one for
you le'veon
you know i'm from new york city right
you i'm sure you're aware of that
of course of course you know what you
know what you knew a team i rooted for
growing up right le'veon
are you aware of that team no no that
would be the team that you're playing
for right now levion okay
all right okay so uh
on behalf of all those people i grew up
with and
they're sitting there in the new york
city area putting so much hope
into you putting so much desire and hope
and wishes into you le'veon bell
you've been through the wars with the
new england patriots you're aware of
those
dates being circled on the calendar what
can you tell jets fans is coming
in that direction from you le'veon bell
i mean there's a lot of hope we have a
lot of we have a lot of upside
going in our direction you know i'm not
saying here saying i want to promise a
playoff spot we're not probably going to
beat the pacers not probably to be a
super bowl winner
but what i'm telling you is we're going
to be a better team it's going to be one
of the best teams that we have seen in a
long time you know
um i see the growth defense those guys
compete with us every day
um and the fact that we're competing
with them every day will only make each
other better and i'm excited
um about what this team does i know i'm
a little conflicted because i'm not used
to rooting for you playing in green and
white le'veon you know that
yeah i know ain't that crazy it's
amazing
what's old is new again all right and
then before i let you go i'll give you
the floor what what's going on with your
music i saw you dropped something on
twitter
what do you got yeah yeah you know i'm
actually going to drop a single
um here in the next week um it's going
to be crazy i'm glad you're going to let
me plug it so
everybody be able to look out for that
it's called bishop pieces uh we're going
to drop in next week so everybody's
ready for that
but so if it's about missing pieces it's
not about the jets right
at all absolutely not okay just want to
make sure
le'veon bell let's that be a stranger
okay i want you on my show i'm
i'm going to be keeping an eye out for
you and i'm going to keep my guy chris
in check best i can okay
you can help me
lots of stretching lots of hydrating
levion
okay that's leviant you got it you got
le'veon bella the jets right here on the
rich eisenship for more of the rich
eisen show
tune to audience channel 239 on directv
for free on br live or download the rich
eisen show app